[Applause]
mi nombre es alejandro Olmedo soo can't
endure a opera you can Tavo incessant a
quarter pies por todo el mundo gentleman
Torah Igor
Lamech a chicken yo Rita Sarah Opera hy
as you go la gente Disqus absurdo can
pero para key in k-town pero this
incredibly porque la ventana Houston
[Music]
sólo los lunas a king and Sangamon
restaurant a cantamos a las siete de la
noche opera invitamos ma siempre can't
antes in Vienna and Sopranos burritos
phenols yes a most una Buena Fiesta aqui
y la pasamos mara-vee-oso
ancestor yo starting a restaurant a
estaba en rusia cantando por varios años
gente en to score intensity concerts
Porto Rusia como en siento cincuenta
ciudades in P secondary pre-k is to yo
estaba sing asura nada a the pronto
yeah no chemicals here tour CT shows up
in Halawa the tiger balm in Omaha say we
get to say hi after the danger of her
how is the minute 319
yes Tina so chummy on Teletoon millions
are amigo the chin guru saw the only
High seniors hollering Hamada really
Kaname Kuran jared ago so in the Hammond
saw my son Aryan young muchacha go sort
of sing of the hell
crong crong Judaica quinceañeras mir
monochorionic Torelli is me mejor amigo
numero uno you stoie we content and we
LG the kill you think is a treble Akio
they they can't reveal de l'opéra de
Campo Alessandra de perón Gotham colony
Mission Control mozzarella casa da -
hundred or a hollow Machado yo cuando
cuando un gran Teatro canto compassion
con la verdad con todo mi corazón y
cuando cuando un restaurante a a wall
uno a donde CL you know de cantar
contour contour the most powerful thing
about being a metal singer is the
complete release
[Music]
I teach people how to scream effectively
without damage but I'm also a singing
teacher
my background is Shakespeare and opera
I got known for being a scream teacher
because I figured this out and I'm glad
I did because everyone was trashing
themselves instead of going red I want
most metal kids before they get trained
they think that the only way that you
can get that sound is to feel that way
and that's dangerous
because if you feel that way when you
make that sound it hurts
everything I teach them the least amount
of effort to do it and then they don't
trash their vocal cords metal is like it
has a certain behavior and it's about
loyalty it's real
[Music]
music is one of those things that just
reaches people and I feel like opera
kind of specifically has that effect on
everyone poor it's raw and it's
beautiful I do feel like we're making it
so everyone can enjoy it
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Alexis Krieger and I'm an
opera singer a member of the opera
collective we're about 30 right now we
come together two to three times a week
to bring opera to the people we sing in
the subways of New York City my mom used
to always listen to the Met broadcasts
when I was 14
she took me to the met for the first
time and queen of the night came on
stage and I saw her and I said that's
what I wanted to
[Music]
most people do have that initial feeling
of oh I don't like afro what is this
opera but bringing opera to the subway
really makes it for everyone and it
really makes it something that people
feel like they can connect with
[Music]
it's one of those places where people
just go by everyday all day long and so
you really get to see all walks of
people
[Music]
we've had people come and stand or sit
for practically the entire time were
there we had a note that was given to us
by a girl who was really not doing that
well that day she was sitting on one of
the benches and she was there for
probably close to two hours and at the
end of it she came up and put this note
along with some change into the bucket
[Music]
basically she had said that she had been
contemplating suicide and listening to
us sitting there and hearing that music
it just it changed her mind and that's
why we do this
I'm so happy that we can make that sort
of impact you know it's it's a really
beautiful thing the first time like I
laid down the guitar track and then play
the fiddle on top of this it make me you
have goose-bumpy
shamanic
[Music]
my name is nature gong-gong berger i am
a musician
I'm originally from China but I have a
Mongolian ancestry
so this our Mongolian fiddle we call
that money [ __ ] or in the English we
can say a horse head fiddle
throat singing is a very ancient and
traditional way of singing you press
your throat and you you generate one a
sound but then you generate an over tune
on the top of the within your mouth oh
it sounds like it sounds like to sound
at the same time
[Music]
if you read the Mongolian history this
all about those brave warrior conquer
all around the world and they don't fear
death you know that kind of spirit
mento people heavy-metal people it's
also like you know very manly you don't
give a [ __ ] you just do whatever you
want you know like this free free
experience definitely free experience
people will say oh why you are doing
Mongolian music they don't understand
the whole ancestry thing they don't
understand your own culture identity but
at the end of day I love the Mongolian
culture and that's all what it matters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's something about standing on
stage and thinking about the people that
have doubted me in the past standing on
stage and thinking about the people who
I would say hello to and they were just
look at me and keep on walking it's in
that moment where I'm on stage where
none of that matter where people see me
as more than just a janitor
I am Kenan Kyle's I am an
internationally touring opera singer I
performed it Lincoln Center in Carnegie
Hall and the Chicago theater and all
these amazing venues but at the end of
the day in order to support those dreams
and support my life I am a janitor I am
a janitor because spills are something
that is very real and as you get older
they get bigger the assumptions that
people have about janitors are that they
are uneducated impoverished I cannot
tell you how many looks I've got it and
the side eyes because they just think
that are you just a janitor it's so
interesting because they never took the
time to really know who this person is
that is cleaning up after them being an
opera singer is very hard it's not easy
technically because opera music is very
complex
I meet with my vocal coach / mentor once
or twice a week but I myself rehearse
probably two hours on top of that a day
I am currently rehearsing this lead role
of Rigoletto for the client opera
group's production and Scotland we're
gonna let those my first title role
which makes this moment so amazing for
me because the whole opera is about him
and his story coming from being a
janitor to starring in a shell is very
empowering being a janitor has humbled
me and has grounded me so much you have
to hold on to yourself because nobody
cares about your dreams more than you do
[Music]